breaking news from the Democratic
presidential race where a national poll
out this morning shows how much Mike
Bloomberg is affecting the campaign it
finds the former New York Mayor is now
in second place with 19% support behind
Bernie Sanders who has jumped into a
commanding lead at 31% that 19%
qualifies Bloomberg to debate the other
candidates for the very first time
tomorrow night in Nevada
Nikole Killion is in Las Vegas Forrest
Nicole good morning so the campaign is
responding how exactly good morning to
you Tony and this morning Michael
Bloomberg's campaign responded by saying
that qualifying for this debate shows
that the former mayor's message is
resonating with Americans and he looks
forward to competing with the other
candidates on stage
Wednesday night keep in mind Bloomberg
is not running here in Saturday's
caucuses where the candidates are
reaching out to a more diverse group of
voters having a cabinet having a team
that is like the rest of America matters
we've got to have representation
candidates are making their final
pitches in a state where a third of the
electorate is black for Latino I have
had historically overwhelming support
from the African American community with
a comfortable lead in Nevada Bernie
Sanders campaign in California and
Washington State already looking ahead
to States or there will be a new
candidate on the ballot in New York City
policies risk CBS News has learned
Sanders aides have privately expressed
concern that Michael Bloomberg with his
415 million dollars in campaign spending
would emerge as their most formidable
opponent I'm Mike Bloomberg
I approve this message and for the first
time the former New York City Mayor
targeted Sanders directly in a new
digital ad accusing Sanders of ignoring
some of his supporters aggressive
tactics likening them to President Trump
back in Nevada 26,000 voters have
already participated in early voting
some waited as long as four hours in
line we'll try again tomorrow I don't
know if I'll have enough volunteers
after the debacle at the Iowa caucus
volunteer Seth Morrison is worried when
we ask on the training this morning how
that will work what kind of data what
kind of charts they said we're working
on a video to show you how the paper
backup works well Nevada
scrapped the app that was used in the
Iowa caucuses but state party officials
say that they are confident that they
have a secure and efficient process in
place Gale well what they tell us in New
Hampshire nichole you can't hack a
pencil pencils always work thank you
very much